pasta's one of those great staple foods
that probably everyone has in their
pantry everyone's made it there's
versions of it in almost every culture
everyone's cooked a bad batch of pasta
that's overcooked and mushy or clumped
together in a big wad of pasta but
here's some tips to make it come out
great every time when you're cooking
pasta first things first you want to
start with a big pot of boiling water if
you have a wider bottom it will heat up
a little bit quicker but the biggest
thing you want to worry about is just
making sure you have enough water in the
pot so that the pasta can move around
freely and that will help it from
clumping up the water will come to a
boil faster if you cover the pot with a
lid some people want to salt the water
while it's cold thinking that it will
help the water boil quicker studies show
that it doesn't make a huge difference
unless you're adding a crazy amount of
salt to the water so it doesn't really
matter if you add your salt to the water
before it's boiling or afterwards the
biggest point was just make sure that
you salt it if you don't salt the water
then the pasta is going to taste really
bland and just not right we're going to
use two tablespoons of salt for this
amount of water don't be afraid to
really heavily salt your water the old
folklore is you want to taste salty like
the sea it seems like a lot but most of
it's going to go out with the water and
only a minimal amount is going to
actually get into the pasta when you add
your pasta you want to get it submerged
in the water as quickly as possible and
you also want to get it moving as
quickly as possible the first minute or
two is the most crucial part to make
sure that it's not going to stick
together so you just want to make sure
that you're getting all the pasta moving
and throughout the cooking process
you're going to want to do this every
few minutes until it's done it may seem
tedious and annoying but it's better to
do it at this point than have a big
clump of pasta at the end before you
drain your pasta preserve yourself a cup
or two of this starchy cooking water
we're going to add this to our sauce
later it's going to give it a nice silky
texture without thinning it out too much
because of all that starch in there
really the only way to tell when your
pasta is done is to taste it when the
pasta goes in you want to set a timer
for about two minutes before the pasta
should be done according to the box
that's a great time to start checking
the pasta to see where you're at and
what we're looking for here is for the
pasta to be al dente al dente just means
to the tooth which means it still has a
little bit of bite in the pasta it's not
completely soft when you bite down
taking it out when it's al dente and
still has that texture to it will keep
it from overcooking once you add it to
the sauce and it cools down enough for
you to eat it so you want to drain your
pasta and do not rinse your pasta unless
you're using it for a cold pasta salad
if you rinse the pasta at this stage
it's just going to take off all of that
extra starch that helps make your sauce
really silky and delicious the longer it
sits like this the more it'll stick
together so immediately after draining
you want to put into whatever sauce
you're going to have if you're not sure
which sauce to pair with your pasta a
lot of it comes down to personal
preference a good rule of thumb for a
long thin noodle like spaghetti angel
hair or linguine is to pair it with a
lighter oil-based or a light cream sauce
here's an example of a quick and easy
sauce you can make while your pasta is
cooking all you really need is some
olive oil some crushed garlic a few
handfuls of fresh chopped tomatoes
season those with a little bit of salt
and pepper that's going to help the
tomatoes release more of their juices
cook those down a little bit then pour
in some white wine and let that reduce
to a nice syrupy sauce and then at this
point you can throw your pasta in
because of the heat of the sauce in the
pan the pasta is going to keep cooking
for another minute or two it's gonna
soak up all that sauce as well so it's
really gonna flavor the noodle in the
last minute or two of cooking at the
last minute you can add some cheese
fresh basil and a little bit of that
pasta water to kind of finish off the
sauce and give it a nice silky creamy
texture and that's it a fresh sauce like
this can take a really basic ingredient
like spaghetti and turn into a really
elegant meal quickly easily and cheaply
so twist pasta like fuzzily rotini
jamelli those are great for lighter
smooth sauces like a pesto because the
sauce can really cling and get into
every nook and cranny of the pasta so at
this point we can just kind of loosen up
the pasta a bit with some of that pasta
water put a few dollops of the pesto
sauce as needed on there and then at
that point you can stir it around
see how much you need add more pesto if
you're crazy like us and really want a
lot in there and you can add a little
bit more cheese and pasta water just to
finish off the sauce and make it nice
and smooth you can really see in the end
just how much of that sauce really soaks
up into the pasta and you'll get a great
bite of pesto with every bite for a rich
meaty sauce something like a ragu or a
bolognese a tube pasta like a rigatoni
pakeri penne all of those are really
great for hanging on to a rich meaty
sauce so add your noodles to the pan add
some pasta water to loosen them up and
then you can spoon in whatever sauce
you're using stir the pasta to keep it
cooking and distribute the sauce really
well in the dish and then at this point
you can add more sauce if you want and
then just to finish off the sauce you
can add some pasta water and some cheese
and then just stir to incorporate it and
melt the cheese in the sauce that's
really going to solidify your dish and
make everything kind of come together
tubes are great because it leaves enough
room for some meat and some of those
bigger chunkier ingredients to get
inside all those are really great for
pairing with a big heavy meat sauce
another less traditional way to cook
pasta is the one pot method and that
really just means cooking the pasta in
the ingredients for the sauce instead of
doing them separately it's a little bit
less traditional but if you need to get
dinner on the table and you don't want a
lot of mess this is a great solution for
that here's an easy one that'll give you
a great result people won't be able to
tell it's a one pot so first you want to
heat up some olive oil get it pretty
nice and hot throw in some chicken some
one pot meals throw everything in at the
same time you know that works but also
then some things are overcooked some
things are undercooked this recipe does
everything in stages but it ends up with
such a great result that no one will be
able to know that it was a one pot we're
gonna brown our protein first with some
salt and pepper on a high heat get a lot
of caramelization on the outside and
then take it out and put it back in at
the very end it's going to give your
chicken a lot more flavor and it's also
going to flavor everything else you add
to the pot afterwards you can add a
little bit more oil if you need it then
you can add your onions and brown those
off a little bit and then you can add
mushrooms and garlic and at this point
any dry seasonings you want to add you
can add them now we used thyme paprika
salt and pepper we want to do that
before we add the liquid so we can toast
the spices slightly that's going to help
release more flavor before we add the
liquid we're going to add some chicken
broth and cream bring that to a boil and
then we can add our pasta shorter or
smaller pasta is great for a one pot
just because it's easy to stir from the
get go you have so many ingredients in
there and there's not as much liquid as
you'd normally use you want to stir
every minute or two just to ensure that
all the pasta is cooking evenly and that
nothing's sticking it should take about
the same time as cooking in normal water
sometimes it takes a little bit longer
especially if your liquid isn't at a
total boil when you start but again the
best way to check it is by tasting it so
about a few minutes before all the
liquid is dissolved you want to taste
your pasta make sure that it's pretty
much al dente and at this point we're
going to add some fresh spinach to it
let that wilt down and add our chicken
back in to finish cooking and get coated
in all that nice sauce as always adding
some parmesan cheese will help thicken
everything up that'll help finish off
the sauce and bring it all together one
pots are great because not only are they
mess-free you have a ton of flavor built
into them because you're boiling the
pasta in this really rich flavorful
broth you're building a ton of flavor
really quickly no one will be able to
tell it's a one pot pasta pasta is one
of those foods that you can never get
sick of it's so versatile it's cheap
it's filling it's a comfort food if you
do it right it can be part of a
nutritious diet and there's so many
different ways to make it you'll never
get bored with it and once you get the
fundamentals down you'll only elevate
your dish every time
like no one will ever be upset if you
put a bowl of pasta in front of their
face that's true that's very accurate
like i wish people liked me that way
that they love pasta